من هذه الحدود شنت روسيا عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا ومنها تعزز قدراتها
الدفاعيه وبها ستنتهي من بناء منشاه تخزين
للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه في الاول من
يوليو المقبل انها بيلاروسيا هذه الدوله
الشرق اوروبيه التزمت الصمت لايام بعد
اعلان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
للاتفاق على نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه على
اراضيها هي في كلا الحالتين الحليف الاكبر
لموسكو بل انها قد تستعد بشكل مباشر
للدخول في الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي سبيلها
لذلك بررت نشر رؤوس نوويه روسيه بالمخاوف
المشروعه حيث اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
البيلاروسيه في بيانها ان البلاد سوف تتخذ
اجراءات ردا اضطراريه بسبب الضغوط الغربيه
على خلفيه تعزيز القدرات العسكريه على
اراضي الدول المجاوره الاعضاء في النيتو
مضيحه ان ذلك لا يتعارض مع احكام المادتين
الاولى والثانيه من معاهده الحد من انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه
ولفتت الخارجيه الى ان بيلاروسيا تتعرض
منذ سنتين ونصف السنه للضغوط غير مسبوقه
من جانب الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وحلفائهما مندده بالتدخل في شؤون منسك
الداخليه اما الاتحاد الاوروبي توعد منسك
بعقوبات جديده في حال نشر هذه الاسلحه
خطوه كان قد تردد بها بوتين لكنه وبعد
اتخاذ القرار قال ان امريكا تفعل ذلك منذ
عقود ووفقا لمركز الحد من التسلح وعدم
الانتشار هناك نحو 100 سلاح نووي امريكي
مخزن في اوروبا عبر ست قواعد في خمس دول